right thank you so much for that call
clint let's go to kirsten in cincinnati
kirsten what is up oh you know i'm just
feeling grateful for you and everyone at
ramsey solutions and that beautiful rant
you just did
and to be talking to you on the phone
well i am grateful for you
how can i help this morning good i'm
pretty awesome
so i agree i fully agree yes thank you
so my main question would be kind of
where's the line between
drinking a lot and alcoholism and then
for me i guess it's pertaining somewhat
to my husband
and i'd like to preface with preface
with he's an amazing man he's very kind
and thoughtful hard working
he treats me with lots of love and
kindness and respect and tenderness and
makes me feel loved
so i'm in a safe environment and it's
good
but i just noticed a lot of times well
we're both coming from very opposite
backgrounds on the topic
my upbringing well as pertaining to
alcohol
it was just never really around my
parents didn't drink my grandparents
didn't drink my great-grandparents
didn't drink we didn't have
alcohol really at family functions it
wasn't until i was older till you start
noticing like oh some of those family
drinks
but they're those families right ooh
those families and
growing up in church it was kind of a
alcohol wasn't great but it wasn't
really elaborately talked about and it
was just
kind of don't get drunk and so that was
the extent of that
and then my husband comes from irish
catholic backgrounds and
that's like all they did they know how
to participate
that's right yes yes and all like great
hearted people
fun stuff too but i will be 31 this week
and
i didn't have my first adult drink till
i was probably 24 26
i've probably had four or five just
never worth the calories
and i'm somewhat of a controlled person
so i'm like i'd rather just do nothing
than risk trying to figure out stuff so
um but just him specifically
he grew up in a household though where
his mom was an alcoholic
and she was that way pretty much from
drinking age until she was about
40 and then she passed away at 45
due to a health condition and then his
dad was very
black and white and he traveled a lot as
a profession so he'd be gone two three
four days a week
and he had a one brother who was
mentally disabled and um the capacity of
about a two-year-old
and so a lot of times he would come home
and his mom would be
passed out on the couch or whatever and
he'd have to fill in and be
the adult so he's had he's had he's had
lots of trauma there right
yes yes absolutely so i know
sorry go ahead i'll say go ahead so get
bring me down to the apex here
okay so um just we've been married for
two years
and i've known him for three okay he's
33 i'm 31
and we i knew that he drank some
but before and it doesn't really bother
me when it's social settings or
just like here and there but i just
noticed
it kind of creeping up more and more and
more and obviously
this past year trying to have the grace
of like well it is a pandemic
and extra stress and things like that
but just
where things to kind of watch for
because i so want to
protect our connection and not project
onto it
and i want boundaries not barriers and
just how to
recognize when it crosses down healthy
and i'm going to take a breath
sure okay all right so that was a lot
and you actually called with one
question and you asked me about
five different questions okay yes sorry
um hey that's okay that's all right and
i can tell
it's deep in your heart and i can tell
you love this guy
and as happens to all of us who get
married
all of us who find ourselves in some
sort of deep relationship with somebody
and in fact i'll go bigger than marriage
this happens at work
this happens with friendships this
happens
in marriages happens in dating
relationships when you find yourself
in love with somebody when you find
yourself
trusting somebody when you find yourself
in relationship with somebody deep
relationship
and then suddenly a behavior that
doesn't line up with your values
doesn't mean it's right or wrong
inherently but it's not a part of your
values
is a part of theirs right and
you're faced with a different picture of
what something
looked like i was raised like you were
there wasn't any alcohol in my house
there wasn't alcohol in my grandad's
house
it was a shock to me to find out in my
probably 20's that my granddad used to
drink beer
and he said to the family i quit
drinking beer i quit buying beer when i
had to buy milk for my babies
it was an economic decision and years
down the road
i ingested that as a moral and character
thing
my dad was a homicide detective he
worked
every day in the lives of people who had
one drink too many and suddenly the rest
of their life
has changed right and
so i again i absorbed that
as a moral character issue
then i went to college and the statute
of limitations hasn't run out on all
those things and so i won't tell all
those stories but i came to
understand that there were some really
extraordinary young men and women
who i got to meet who were from all over
the country who grew up with different
attitudes around alcohol
i had some close close friends two of
which are brothers two of which are my
best friends on planet earth
irish catholic and you know what they
had way more
fun than i did they did they danced more
than i did they sang more than i did
they
could play music better than i could and
they had a family that celebrated
big time right with good drinks and good
food
and good camaraderie and so those were
initially
value issues for me whoa this is as you
said so eloquently
one of those families and it turns out
that um second to my parents
their parents had a major influence on
me in a positive way
their um friendship has had a major
relation a major impact on me
relationally throughout my life right
and so it could go on and on and on all
that to say is this
your husband has experienced a lot of
trauma in his life
from mom passing away at a really young
age
mom being a functional alcoholic dad
being an on-the-road salesman
your husband having to be a surrogate
parent to a special needs brother
and and and and so what he has
is a model of marriage
a model of relationship that is going to
be different than yours
okay and so i've got way more concern
and concern's a dramatic word there i've
got way more
um i have my eyes closer to that do your
differing pictures of what marriage
looks like what relationships will look
like
ongoing than i do about
alcohol if you are safe and you are kind
and he is kind and he loves you and he
is there for you
then i that's not my worry right now
um i definitely think it's worth
you guys seeing a marriage counselor for
for a regular amount of time like for
ongoing
to work through your differing pictures
of what a relationship's going to be and
you all co-create he gets a voice you
get a voice in something together
you are not going to be able to protect
this by yourself
he's going to have to be invested in
this and he's going to have to do a lot
of
transition and change and you're going
to have to do a lot of compromise and
transition yourself
as you all you'll create a marriage
that's going to be different than
anything you all to have ever
experienced
now to go back to your original question
the difference between drinking
and being an alcohol addict those two
things are different
alcohol addict is somebody that is used
as alcohol as a way to escape
an addict is somebody that cannot do
without
okay they have to have this to get
through a day they have to get this
have this through to get through an
event they have to have this
to get through a week and ultimately
an addiction starts impairing your life
right it does usually start
not always but it starts in a rather
benign fashion
a glass of wine after work and then a
couple of days a week that glass of wine
turns into two or three
or i just have a beer a couple of beers
after work every day
and then on fridays i have four or five
and then saturday morning i have a
bloody mary just because whoa
and then i go ahead and start drinking
saturday afternoon at four or five and
it's just i'm just having
i'm just having some whiskey just having
a bourbon that's it and um
i'm gonna class it up a little bit and
suddenly
i'm doing it every day suddenly those
one drink or two beers
a day become three they become four and
suddenly i'm not having fun without it
i'm not sleeping without it i'm not
filling the blank without it
and now you got a problem right and so
my guess is your husband doesn't have a
model for
someone who loves him and says hey i've
noticed
you going from year one to having a
couple of beers when we'd go on dates
or a couple of beers we hang out to
we're in a pandemic now and
now you're drinking every single day so
the concern one is the drinking right
that's fair but he's not gonna have a
picture for what somebody who loves him
and is wanting to have a conversation
with him looks like and that's gonna
feel very judgy to him
it's going to feel very heavy to him
does that make sense
yes and we had that conversation how'd
it go over it because
it was it was um
he kind of uh takes space
processes things and then comes out um
a lot of times like on the positive side
but it was never really like
oh yeah that was right it just starts
like drinking less
like it starts registering with him and
because
it was that kind of thing it was like oh
once a week and now it's like
twice a week and it went from two to
three and i just kind of said like have
you noticed
the past couple months that you've like
increasingly done
this and now we're here and it
and it was kind of a half response of
uh that's like just the way that i was
raised it almost feels like
alcohol to him is this friend and this
like
um like it doesn't feel like it's full
on gotten to
like that addiction part it's just this
coping mechanism friend
of like oh this is what i go to here
this is what i go to when i fish this is
what i go to when i clean my gun this is
what i go to
because it's friday night and those kind
of increased more and i did kind of say
like have you noticed that
and sometimes it's like i like the taste
or whatever sometimes he just been
doesn't drink for
a month like it just kind of varies in
the situation right and
yes so what you're gonna have to really
work hard at in this new relationship
you're gonna have to really work hard is
staying out of his head
because the way you just described that
to me is
you asked him a question he gave you an
answer and then you judge the answer
because you didn't believe him
you got into his head and you were
deciding why he's drinking more
you got into his head and decide he may
just like to taste when he's cleaning
his gun
it may just be a moment of zen and
chilling out and he's having a beer
while he's cleaning his gun
or he's just having a beer with some
buddies while he's going fishing
that's not weird that's not unnatural or
normal and that doesn't mean he's got a
problem
right it goes back to
y'all are gonna have to work on not the
alcohol yet
you're gonna have to work on your
communication and you have a picture
where alcohol is bad i can hear it in
your voice you've got a picture where
alcohol consumption
is not good or right or to use religious
terms it's not holy
it is a crutch it's a less than
and he doesn't have that picture
and so what you guys need to work on
together is reframing it
and if you don't want alcohol in your
home you got to just be honest with him
and tell him
you're probably gonna have to have like
say it when you're in therapy
right say it when you're the marriage
counselor and you've got a neutral third
party there
but if you're always gonna have this
tension around it if you're always gonna
have this
little bit of judgment against him
leaning up against him for this
particular behavior
and i'm talking to everybody now this
doesn't just mean alcohol this could be
going to the gym this could be
wearing a mustache dudes or the way
this particular um shoes look or
whatever the thing is if you've got that
little bit of judgment against somebody
i just don't like the way you smack and
you chew your food i'm never going to
say anything just don't like it
then what you're doing is you're putting
a tiny splinter
in your relationship you're putting a
tiny wedge between each each of you
and over time that wedge just gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and all
sorts of things
fall in there that never should have
been there in the first place
right things of not much consequence
fall into this gap and they
feel so big even though they're not even
though they're not
so the question the difference between
drinking and alcohol
being being an alcohol addict being an
addict means you can't function without
it
right it impairs your everyday life
having a few beers while you're fishing
with your buddies doesn't sound like an
alcohol addiction
it sounds like you have a picture of a
husband you have a picture of a home
that doesn't include it
and you and your husband need to get on
the same page about what your marriage
is going to look like
so thank you so so much for that call
kirsten i want you to to
go see a counselor a marriage therapist
with your husband
i want you to have an honest
conversation together and i want you to
call me back and let me know how that
conversation went
i want your husband to do some work on
his childhood trauma he's got he had a
tough road
and it sounds like he is overcoming a
lot by continuing to love you
i want to hear how that conversation
goes so holler back at me thank you so
much for the call